Berner viruses attack the respiratory
system and this curve this corona virus
causes a disease called KO bid 19 now
most cases are mild and similar to the
flu or a cold the symptoms can include a
fever coughing and shortness of breath
they can appear two days or even two
weeks after you are exposed in just over
two months more than ninety-eight
thousand cases have been reported
worldwide the virus has killed more than
3300 people but more than 55,000
patients who had the virus have now
recovered the most severe cases have
been in older people and patients with
pre-existing medical conditions right
now scientists believe the virus spreads
between people in close contact that's
within about six feet of one another
public spaces are being sanitized in
hopes of containing the virus you can
get it from an infected person's cough
or sneeze or possibly by touching
something with the virus on it like a
door handle and then touching your face
the corona virus has spread to six
continents in just three months it was
first detected in December in Wuhan
China where it had previously only been
discovered in animals but jumped to
people from there the virus spread
quickly infecting dozens and forcing the
Chinese government to publicly declare
an outbreak and that outbreak soon
stretched across all of mainland China
and then spread to neighboring countries
including Japan Thailand and South Korea
across the Pacific on that very same day
it appeared in Washington State that is
the first known case in the United
States by February 5th the virus was on
board the diamond Princess cruise ship
docked at the time in Yokohama Japan of
the 3700 passengers on board that ship
the virus infected 706 of them
eventually American passengers were
brought home to military bases here in
the US and the virus unfortunately
hitched a ride with at least 46 of them
meanwhile the virus landed in Iran no
clue as to how it got there it also
exploded in Italy 124 cases became 880
eight cases that is the largest outbreak
to date outside of Asia Germany Britain
Croatia France and Spain have also
reported cases all out all throughout
Europe and then also in the southern
hemisphere Brazil Nigeria Ecuador and
South Africa cases they're all told 89
countries worldwide are now reporting
cases and here in the United States
there are 21 states reporting at least
one case of the corona virus and that
leads us to today one of those states is
New York Meg Oliver is in one of the
nation's busiest transportation hubs New
York City's Penn Station Magna computer
commuters there seem concern
Anthony good morning they tell me that
they are definitely thinking about it
but as you can see they're still going
about their daily routine I commute an
hour a day by bus and subway and I can
tell you that I have seen more people
using hand sanitizer here in Penn
Station more than 650,000 people pass
through here every day that's a lot of
people in packed quarters as coronavirus
fears spread cases doubled to 22 in New
York State Thursday and more than 2,700
people are being monitored now
nationwide there are at least 230
confirmed cases of corona virus at least
12 deaths 11 of those in Washington
State
now those fears are creating a rush on
hand sanitizers masks and cleaning
supplies sending sales up an estimated
eight hundred and seventeen percent
store shelves are empty across the
country we went to a supply company in
New Jersey where employees are working
overtime to keep up with demand the
company's owner says it's hard to
restock because many of the products are
made in China cargo ships aren't the
only ones being kept from our shores now
for all of these people traveling by
rail Amtrak tells us they are cleaning
more trains and stations and using more
disinfectant Gayle all right Meg thank
you very much our Asia correspondent
Ramey
innocencio has reported on this outbreak
from across the region first in January
from the virus epicenter in Wuhan China
then from South Korea that was in
February now in March he's in Japan
we're a meet Tokyo let's talk about that
first it's usually a bustling city
what's it like now
gaile good morning I'm at the famous
Shibuya crossing think of it as Tokyo's
version of Times Square really one of
the world's busiest intersections right
behind me now up to 2,500 people cross
this thoroughfare every single time
these lights change and if you can
believe it this Friday night right here
this is actually relatively peaceful now
here in Japan more than 300 people have
been confirmed to have coronavirus
unfortunately at least six people have
now died but the interesting thing is
that only about 900 people each day
actually get tested for the virus now
that really truly pales in comparison to
the country just west of us that of
course is South Korea where about 10,000
people that's right 10,000 people get
tested every single day there so far
South Korea has more than 6,000
confirmed cases that's the most for any
country outside of China but the death
rate get this is relatively lower and
only about 0.7 percent now that could be
thanks to innovative measures like
drive-through testing you heard that
right
where medical workers decked out in
protective clothing actually screen
drivers who get to stay behind the
wheels of their cars now earlier I spoke
to Sharon prophet she's an American
teacher in Daegu where most of South
Korea's infections are happening she
told me she actually feels safer there
than the United States
what can the u.s. learn from what's
happening where you are I think
transparency is a huge deal I think
having being more prepared for potential
outbreaks I don't think America is
prepared and Japan now says that
starting this Monday they are going to
be quarantine any traveler coming from
China or South Korea for the 14 days
that they are still in this country and
of course looking ahead to this summer
don't forget Tokyo is host of the Summer
Olympics that starts in July just about
three and a half months from now they
say that preparations are still
continuing at least for now Tony
but nowadays ramyon Ascencio in tokyo
for a me thank you very much
Italy was the first European country to
ban flights from China but that did not
stop the virus from ballooning out of
control there Charlie d'Agata is in Rome
forest where the Italian government
faces a massive challenge okay right
away let's get to those numbers
overnight the largest single-day
increase since this outbreak began there
are now nearly 39 hundred cases 148
people have died we're outside Italy's
number one Hospital for infectious
diseases and you might just be able to
make out those silver tents behind me
that's essentially a triage and you see
them outside hospitals especially in the
north which has been hardest hit and
this is where people that may have the
infection can be treated and looked
after without spreading the virus to the
rest of the hospital across the country
schools and universities have been
closed it's Halle ins had actually been
urged to keep some distance from one
another which obviously doesn't come
naturally in a country like this this is
also home to Europe's oldest population
the elderly have been advised to stay
indoors for now
what you don't see out on the streets is
a bunch of tourists across the globe
hotel cancellations are up to more than
70% in Italy is at the top of that table
Gayle all right Charlie d'Agata
reporting from Rome thank you